[Music]
you
hello and good evening to our weekly
show this will be the final show for
this year and yeah I hope we have a
couple of guys in the in the chat
channel and yeah let's get going I have
a question actually let's get to one
thing I'm um I'm thinking about today's
today's show and of course I can do like
five minute chest as usual but I was
thinking about maybe if you are
interested I can do a couple of three
minute games and play yeah some offbeat
openings do something else like yeah
player play something a little bit crazy
I don't know it's there some interest in
that or should I just play in the
five-minute pool let's see if I can get
some opinion on that and then I'm going
to do whatever you feel as some
appropriate I don't want to play crazy
stuff in five minute I've I've fought
really hard to get back to a decent
rating and i want to i want to kick that
down the down the drain never got a
couple of positive statements okay come
on let's i'll do a couple of three
minute game Sonya just for the end of
the year so I have a three minute
request out and then we'll see attend
attacking the bullet not know what
attack in Berlin nine people that okay
and terrorists again I didn't watch the
two just didn't watch the news
game started so now i'm not i'm not
going to play the grope attack or
something but just play a little bit
aggressive a little bit offbeat so yeah
this one can become interesting just
play in an aggressive way here on the
kingside it should be three I don't know
this this looks kind of kind of
dangerous on on g6 let's see if he feels
the need to cover it so so so let's take
the center here with c4 and 293 yeah
he's giving me the e4 square this is
good news and now happily install the
bishop only four yep cover everything if
he takes on you for I will take with the
with the pawn okay so what now it seems
he wants to Castle long think the Queen
can go away here
can someone can someone bend this person
there in the in the chat the spammer so
yeah Nyjah for maybe I'm and after look
at them have to look at the clock there
it is three minutes at three minute is
not what I usually do
[Music]
yeah he wants to trade this off but I
have a second night yeah hmm ok i have
an ID f7 in this position I don't know
if this is so great though my bishop
p.m. I probably have to get this back
anyway ok let's get there and I need to
go b5 some somewhere soonish we take
that huh I can take with the pawn as
well that limits black enormously let's
do this and maybe be five yeah you will
play a g5 maybe
I is defending this quite well I have to
say age three not not fantastic ready
allowing this was not exactly yep
exactly what I wanted so what's what's
going on here he wants to play Queen age
seven i guess i need to get the g porn
somehow time morning maybe I have to do
this here I will take with the pole it's
a pretty bad position can take you five
maybe check
I don't know if a my chick made it here
Luke cheeks I don't see it check check
check no no I'm Jenna save him check
check don't think he has a perpetual
check no yeah there were many many
possible waiting for him to play better
I think
[Music]
black resign yep what's dangerous
dangerous for both of us I guess gain
started a 10-game bloom aureus ok so i
will play something wacky so let's play
the latvian it's entirely incorrect but
you never know what happens this is
Grand Master Kovalenko is a very high
rate at 2,600 player this is one of the
good lines for white there are many good
lines against us against this opening
this is one of them so c6 ok I see of
course mm-hmm not good check not good
but ok any 95 Queen g2 there are still
some funky things going on why should be
better you of course but it has some it
is some unclear points at least by
Bishop erf 8 is bad this is a real issue
[Music]
[Music]
check check and then that could have
been worse I think can someone please
bend this idiot all right Dharma don't
give me all right yeah those guys and
they just need a big head check
so
so can we do something here at least I'm
not mated immediately but it looks
pretty awful okay so I got this this
hour and now is there some kind of way
to get counterplay not really am check
one paw down and problems
so
yeah just just couldn't be six probably
I know this doesn't probably do much at
the end time morning yes the time is got
be 3m
[Music]
yeah it's unfortunately lost in 10 the
points from old ok black and goes on a
challenge so I know so let's go for a
new game yeah unfortunately I cannot
bend I'm not a channel admin
[Music]
so I'm gonna new game started a new
request out Freddie okay let's see what
we get against Freddy what kind of
freddie is that no name one with ramiro
over here oh oh my god and so oops so we
can do something active here certainly
yeah maybe h3g for me up this is fairly
aggressive this is also what I will play
in five min so it's not a big difference
now I have to take with a queen yeah
that was a big one I have that was a bad
bad mistake I have to I needed to play
Queen takes to form
so here I am night f5 looks like the
right move those parts could be reading
the ends but she will see what happens
yeah I don't really see something great
for him he takes quite a bit of time we
can take a five immediately of course
yeah so I'm going to take check yeah 97
maybe I'll 96 yeah i bet i have this one
yeah i will get before I just want to
ever have something better probably not
but this is a good a good position I
believe my pawn structure here doesn't
really matter 94 though that could be a
point yeah I'm bishop see one
[Music]
okay wants to play nite nite receive for
now yeah defended this quite well what
did two Germans eat at Christmas usually
are there are a couple of things
possible and we don't we have some
traditional German ones but i usually do
something which is small so its
associated with switzerland i go for
rock ledge yeah which is some maybe by
to shush White's I can tell something
about this
so what's going on here and I'm one is
difficult to do something here
I can try I mean I can try this but it
doesn't do much him know he doesn't even
try she's six doesn't help
[Music]
yeah there will be some Christmas dreams
very likely on my own channel I'm not I
don't have anything scheduled yet
because the the family meetings are not
yet clear I'm down on time that's kind
of crazy check didn't really see it
seven seconds check oh nice playing this
quite badly plane coming working on time
yeah come on don't give me challenges
guys yeah yeah that's what it very
nicely explained in the in the shed
where the rock ledges it's male cheese
with potatoes and vegetables and it's
very nice did I actually wait yep
accidentally clicked on the on the wrong
wrong button down
as saw some games from the London
Chester's yes I did one round report and
this was also a nice game Nakamura's win
against mvl caranas game also was very
nice of course so I don't get a new game
started again Freddy with black ok so
what can I do the Latvian was a bit too
crazy it's tough to play something
aggressive against such a stodgy opening
like this Italian game
yet Apollo really looked completely out
of shape in this event
but you already didn't play well in some
other events earlier this year starting
with the candidates where he was playing
so badly that it came close to him yeah
I'm manipulating the competition I found
it became and just I mean the main thing
that was who's going to beat this guy
koala did manage to win with the piece
up against são Paulo which was at the
end decisive so what's going on here I'm
going to try to get some attack going on
the Kings side i have got the somewhat
better development down how dangerous it
is stuff the same yeah Knight f6 I guess
I need all the pieces 93 93 yahoo I
could have done that maybe still next
move
check hmm yeah he some more defended
this position I should have played 93
but I didn't I'd see it too late I just
saw it too late ah what a shame
yeah he wants to get rookie 7n yeah if i
take this is a bad ending okay maybe I
can hold it it's not fun
yeah I could fake some hints if someone
would play while watching the industry
okay here at least I'm up on the clock
and I feel like the drawing Schatzi are
quite decent check yeah I can get four
against three year program check draw
our third any tricks from our Tehran
[Music]
okay so at the end i go to draw them 93
was good at one point but it was i was
tough i was a bit too quick there with
my move so did i type in this room
yep and so we have a couple of title
players on oh we have enough wood a gas
on in the five-minute pool shall I try
some five minute ok I'll try some
private minute then oh I don't know
there are a couple of good guys in the
five-minute pool I'm going to do both
gain started ok we get no no so let's do
something funky don't do that usually at
least before should not be an advantage
for black
so let's see what to do some c4 here I
would like to go see form to a Tekkit
center that is so bad I think this
position seems okay 95 I have to take
but now have to take it yeah I wonder do
I take on b7 or is that a bit dangerous
yeah we'll see it's the kind of move
that is going to be critical um yeah my
king side looks a little bit a little
bit under pressure
[Music]
until it's not so much yeah doesn't seem
so dangerous yeah this is something that
I probably should have prevented but
okay I still I feel stuffy that's not so
bad where do I go with the bishop I
don't have very stable position Sam
maybe I can get an a form pieces are
built a bit unstable 390 forms better I
cannot take this because of the
discovery queen to d6 his idea okay I
can always go g3 I think maybe there are
some ideas on the back rank as well that
I can go from
[Music]
yeah the true
yeah try some one minute was a
suggestion in the chat and I really
don't I mean I cannot do commentary on
bullet chest I really cannot I tried
that I mean I can just play you and I
cannot time morning cannot say anything
that makes sense really not nice try and
stuff here but don't see it the real
danger
this might still be a draw the opposite
color do ships probably make this quite
dry I always quadruped the true I was a
stupid stupid play yeah it makes it
pretty simple can I do something at
least we should should be a HR and it
takes this doesn't do anything what is
he doing here playing for made awesome
check checkmate yes yes yeah why do I
get those Viggo position it seems to be
enough yeah I get shake made it against
whoever oh yeah okay so let's play a cup
game starting yeah you know I press five
minute and I get it I get it mr. omegas
here so m let's see what he's up to III
Wow check
I just got a sick high rating that's
cool i mean i'm usually I play lots of
drawers now against himself I don't
really mind that at all now it has
played and this time of day it's not
I've played upon those live shows by the
way if you want to know my score we have
played 44 games and I have seven wins
and 22 losses
this position type I had on the board
once in a tournament game and I invested
some time in that tournament game so i
don't really have to invest much time
now i can just play according to this
we just make a draw giving me a rating
points really game drawn wow wow what's
this I didn't expect that usually he
just shuffles around yeah that was a
little bit anti-climatic but maybe I get
him again if i press 5 quickly yeah I
was really thinking he would do
something else but okay he just gives me
six points so why not
I did one video for the internet chess
club on the London jazz classics i think
it's just on the if you need to be a
member on the of the ICC to watch it I
mean it was a round recap for around
eight hour live men orbits asked at
which level of what level have I tried
to distort deeply learning opening
theory well I actually looked at
openings pretty early on i always felt
interested about them i would say maybe
like 1800 level roughly 1,800 which is
not cannot necessary and it's also not
so clear what what you mean with deeply
it's again started somewhat somewhat
deep but not like doing yeah whatever i
did back then I didn't really look at
books and learnt moose by heart I was
studying old games quite a lot master
games would games spec back then yeah
but what was played half of kasparov or
well Fisher had had retired for for a
long time at this point but I looked at
all fishes games and so on I did lots of
lots of work like this so we have a
terror she tell Russia defense to the
Queens gambit
in this line is very slightly better for
white it's nothing out of the ordinary
but why it is a little bit more
comfortable here check so here White has
a slight edge with this more active
pieces how to play though yeah look the
one or something looks very normal Queen
a form maybe we should be six okay I
play rook you one
[Music]
we have four bishop is six how it's
difficult difficult to make something
real happen here
huh I don't really see much here in
terms of activity maybe this move but my
ideas Bishop is six Bishop g5 trying to
gain some some time they're tough tough
really yeah tix rook takes is a tempo
and I'm a little bit quicker there may
be on the D file g6 I go quinchu g5 I
guess or maybe h6 mi idea was that now
I'm quicker on d7 down so these 7
immediately it doesn't do much look the
18 who hangs this is a bit of an issue
a follows as a netbook so lame looks
very young under namak what is God roop
the aid coming maybe I have to play for
Queen before 21 hours thought I hear the
same Queen the one I control the default
network see one coming maybe it's just
equal Queen f64 oh this feels a bit
better for wide like I'm close to double
on the sea far almost and sorry on the
seventh rank of the sea far so here and
now I'm threatening whoopsie seven
is he going be five yeah good he is
covering f7 am thats that's definitely
definitely true
[Music]
[Music]
Queen d6 threatens rook f7 I don't know
if this is the right one
[Music]
yo keV 7 is the threat and it's probably
not decisive maybe I also have efore
check okay check hmm that's difficult to
get out of if you just place for a draw
here time morning
you
[Music]
let's from this to the draw
[Music]
you cannot make much progress down
[Music]
don't think I'm universe in this
position that i have to take with the
other look oh my god sick okay white
verisign lr just a brain slip yeah just
this end it's a total druid wrong
nothing happens even with the time silly
silly so okay one or two more games this
is very easily am gifting 28 points away
and the position was was really good
here really wonder what been wrong this
was actually very nice wide I mean
losing is this is really out of the
question check it was never worse at any
point okay if you'll under a full moon
dances this is the logical way to end it
with the draw okay I got a game requests
out and let's see ya below 2400 and gala
that sucks gain started I could only Gus
again so you play the same stuff again
make a draw what is going D for you
don't see that too often so I know this
is part of his repertoire this is part
of his repertoire actually
check so what's going on yeah i can t
yeah so he plays and one of those
typical things like you plays I try to
should be five dangerous I don't know
interesting the ikenga Bishop c4 c5 but
I don't know about that it could could
be wrong but we'll see you at the H file
is a bit of an issue here if I take
[Music]
you might take and play b7 this is what
irritates me a bit so let's do this
just cover this for the moment
everything and see what is up to but
take you five you can take with the f
Parliament this is a little bit annoying
at least if it takes and those root g 7i
have would be six and you cannot defend
a bleep on maybe it's got Bishop G sexy
that also opens for aveda form possibly
yeah he wants to go look on the six-year
can still play it up again he also could
have taken a loop just excited blunder
here but you didn't recognize it
[Music]
check
[Music]
pretty bad
[Music]
[Music]
p 3 rogue a 30 pitch working between
scumming
[Music]
three i have i have checks lots of
checks
[Music]
33 unfortunately time warning
[Music]
yeah it's lost unfortunately what is all
this clinging and banging and stuff
maybe I could have played hoop to King
d2i yet check okay yet to check check
okay hmm this is this is still
interesting now he wants to check me
from the back so I had Jesus he still
got me black for effect on time I really
is held I hit something near the enter
right check drawn what is a draw Russia
a trois instead immediately this draws
he's always tough really tough yeah ok
let's go for one more game one more game
and I position was a little bit to gain
started to too boring really against him
so better to play something more
complicated but it's difficult to get my
experience hazel stay da via cassia ok
Shin does window so neither fee that's
an idea that I had when I did my English
theories I think white is better here in
this line let's see what scheana's
window is up Jillian this is better for
wine check wow it just goes into a
completely bad position right okay it's
not it's not like winning immediately
just bad
so what's what's going on here wow
really amazing how quickly he plays all
that it looks really bad maybe I'm just
always amazing things but
[Music]
so look I have six wins the Queen
essentially from some some material not
flow well I can also go back winning the
exchange I wonder it's probably Keenum
when they exchange the Queen win isn't
all that clear
[Music]
like to play d4 of course look fo was
the same thing right no I'm just giving
away I should stop reading the chat
really sometimes I just really ended a
blunder from this position
[Music]
check yeah that's really disappointing
check the way the way that was played
out I should just win it and no I mean
this nothing ending
see you slightly slightly uncomfortable
check check check roll down that's too
little from this position
draw offered game drawn Jeremy there was
a pretty sketchy session all this some
good play is mostly bad place yeah not
winning here's a bit embarrassing really
this all set up books extremely fishy
for black and yeah kangaroo k f6 I
wasn't sure that wins the queen of
course but I wasn't completely sure how
how clean that is like he disposition
wasn't clear to me this is just an
exchange but I've landed it back without
any reason really yeah I can't play
whatever just this song just don't give
it back okay so i hope you enjoyed our
session thanks for watching also thanks
for watching all through the year i
think quite a couple of of the audience
our regular watches every every monday
basically yeah merry christmas happy
holidays have a good start to the new
year i would probably do some live
content on my channel over christmas
check check this out thanks for watching
guys bye bye